these Bryan Cranston the movie is the
upside it's in theaters starting today
he plays a wealthy quadriplegic and he's
with Kevin Hart is also in there Nicole
Kidman julianna margulies and Tate
Donovan the up son opens in theaters on
Friday you did this a while ago how many
years ago when always it's about a year
and a half ago that we finished it up
and then you brought us a prop from the
movie I did and this is how would you
describe the prop that you gave us for
the man cave it's a wooden appendage to
an Anatomy that a man would have okay I
think that's so this this is under the
covers it's under the covers yeah and
then you have a string that's pulled
right I did I had what we could say he
gets an erection quite accidentally and
and and this is what the prop guys came
up with is for me to serve tisha sleep
Oh last ring so that we show and and
this is what happens in real life to
quadriplegics they can't always control
yeah anything so now did you give this
out to everybody you know just us oh no
no just you is that though is that a one
of one it's the only one ever made for
the movie the upside there's a an
anecdote to them no you've got it the
only one I appreciate that are you gonna
sell it now because now it's more
valuable you're gonna like it's the only
one I'm gonna put it on no no I there's
other things that I have Paulie take it
off ebay off even let's take it off me
back what do you think of this color
this sweater that I have on it is it is
a pungent unhorse full color yeah it
doesn't sound good no no it's it's it
would it would look really really good
on some people not on me I'm not
thinking that that's your color
okay I'm looking at my look at this
sweater it looks like a throwback uni
right kind of like I just looked at that
one it looks like the old NFL light back
in the day
with those leather helmets and leather
helmet and it would look I don't know if
that's your color are we gonna do this
all day you're gonna go back you're a
little upset that I don't like your
sweater no I appreciate your honesty
can't you act like you like this you're
a great actor like you like it
I really do I like it speaking of great
acting that wasn't convincing at all if
you get a chance to see a Brian on
Broadway as I did and network and it was
wonderful it was great performance and
you've extended yes your stay yes we're
going all the way through the end of
April now so okay plenty of chances to
come see a New York stage performance
and you can did I see Brian cry you can
see me cry yeah yeah now can you can you
cry right now yes you can yeah okay the
the disaster that that sweater is what
kind of makes me cut you could cry on
cue yeah I mean it's it's not like
you're a machine but but if I start to
think about something and I can bring
tears to my eyes yeah okay are you
asking me I think I sort of was but you
rat you want me to cry right now yeah
hmm I can cry right now okay
are we having a cry off yeah we can I
don't know for crying out loud that's
what we're doing we're crying out loud
this is how you win in these right here
like and you can you can see that my
eyes are watering up a little bit I'm
tearing up a little bit yes you're very
needy this morning I'm this way all the
time we were talking about 20 year
anniversary of The Sopranos and we were
wondering what Breaking Bad have been
made if we didn't have the Sopranos I
don't think so I think what what they
were able to David Chase who was able to
do and creating a character like Tony
Soprano was certainly paving the way to
allow the space for someone like Walter
White to exist yeah it was it was
groundbreaking because you I don't know
if you root for the bad guy but you
don't root against it feels like there
is empathy for the bad guy well it is
it's not that clear what you root for is
humanity when you see the humanity in
Tony Soprano for instance the element of
going to a therapist says he's searching
he's looking for something else looking
for some measure of wholeness as a human
being and that's embraceable and I think
that's why that character work is that
he would go and he would kill someone
and then he'd go home and he'd have to
deal with his sons homework or tardiness
or his wife is complaining her he was
just a guy dealing with the stuff that
we all deal with and you and you go I
know I know what that guy's dealing with
but Walter White didn't go to a
therapist did he and Breaking Bad no he
didn't have he didn't have time he had
the clock was ticking yeah on Walter
White did you think about that was that
ever broached in the in the script that
he would actually be confessing to
somebody I think I think Vince Gilligan
did consider something like that but it
seemed it seemed to slow
the pace and the tempo of what he was
trying to do and as you notice as the
seasons went on it quickened we lost
some of the humor of the earlier seasons
when things got more tense and desperate
and naturally the humor falls away
because it's too horrific to to witness
we also brought up sex in the city came
out before The Sopranos and you know so
here's HBO with Sex in the City which
was you know that was different
yeah I go back to Hill Street Blues as
maybe a TV show that kind of and you
were on an episode of Hill Street Blues
weren't you I was I played Dennis
Francis lawyer well I I was I was I
don't know 28 years old that play is
lawyer wood they're hiring me for the
lawyer really I was surprised but they
did and and yeah that was a
groundbreaking show Steven Bochco and
wonderful wonderful work and and I went
on to do four different productions of
Steven bodka watch goes because his well
you did only long I did at an episode of
LA Law and then I had two experiences
that weren't so good on on his shows one
was called Brooklyn South where I was
hired to play an internal affairs cop
and I never got a script it was just
sides in those days my fax machine at
night wasn't rolling off and you had to
cut the paper
Amida that is like and I would have
reams of dialogue and I'm working at
6:30 tomorrow morning and just blocks
and blocks of dialogue and names and
events and I'm doing I am doing what I'm
saying and so I would just had a
pounding headache throughout the entire
eight days it was terrible
could you have handled success that
you've had now when you're 28 years old
I don't I don't know I mean when I was
25 I moved to New York to be on a soap
opera so and in a small dose I had like
whoa look at that I'm working as an
actor and
dating models from the Ford agency and
things like that it was really I was
fantastic really yeah let's talk about
that oh it was it was a good time yeah
this is the roaring 80s man I was 83 84
did you ever go to studio 54 oh yeah
how'd you do what did you do you just go
and you dance and you and you meet some
people and you go in a back room and you
have some fun and did you have any
famous friends back then no I I was I
didn't know anybody and I was really
young and I I still don't know to this
day who anybody is you know it's like
wait really I really don't I know you
yeah you guys the dads I know these guys
cuz I watched who's your famous friends
now yeah uh Tom Hanks is a friend and
he's he's epic but only because our
wives have known each other for 40 years
maybe longer
it's and so that's how I got to know him
and he's yeah as Tom Hanks ever made you
mad no is he is he capable of making you
mad I think if he did something
Despicable I would be angry but he
doesn't do that no he is he is he's my
role model even though I'm about four or
five months older than here he hit
stardom quickly in his 20s and then held
on to it and then evolved wonderfully
and aged into new roles and but more
than that it's what he was able to set
up for himself personally and I tell
this to young actors all the time you
get your home life set that's your
foundation so make that as sane as
possible so that you can go insane at
work and and tom was I saw that clearly
what he was doing and how he structured
that and and I thought that's what I
want I want to be able to have that
solid and be able to do my work as a
side thing and always be able to come
back home what is the challenge for you
because you've done
you've done drama you've done theater is
there one other I think the newest
challenge right now is looking at you
and that's what I mean it's it's it's
almost hurts your eyes a little bit
doesn't it you have to kind of look up
at your forehead I don't want I can't do
you want me to take this off and just be
topless is that what you're asking well
yes I mean you're big on nudity I'm not
afraid of nudity I'm not afraid of
nudity I don't know if I'd say I'm big
on it but other people looking at me
naked might say I'm big but does your I
know your wife has been you know you've
been married a long time but yeah what
are the years when you're there with the
scene and you're in your underwear or
just your daughter like did you know do
they get embarrassed or do they goof on
you not so much anymore I might you know
they don't watch too much of that my
daughter's an actor too now so we're
it's the family business and and we're
so used to that it's it's like you're
able to have your imaginary life and
your real life separated and and both of
them celebrated who's in their underwear
more often you were Will Ferrell oh I
think will is probably more often and he
does that full-on full-on new thing and
he's got the appendix scar and he's he's
so fearless man he's like bulging over
his his you know he removed his appendix
for the comedy that's that's that's what
he does dedication that's dedication
have you have you ever have you competed
for jobs with I have no idea
I don't I don't know who I really
compete against you don't know who's
auditioned for well I heard I heard like
for Walter White I heard that John
Cusack was name was mentioned
and Matthew Broderick's name was
mentioned and Steve Zahn was mentioned
but that's all I know is that they were
mentioned I don't know if it was ever if
they ever really had meetings or I have
no idea I don't pay any attention to
that do you audition you have to
audition No
well everything's an audition even when
you're not officially reading for
something when you're meeting a director
for a possible role it's an audition
yeah he or she is looking at you going I
think he's right for it or I don't think
he's gonna be right for it and your
intern looked and talking to them about
how do you see this character played out
and do do I think I can work with you
but I would never know meeting you that
you could have been Walter White like
what would you show me if I was a
director and I said okay Brian come on
in and then I would have you read some
things yeah you'd read if there was a
regular audition set up you'd go in and
you'd have what they call sides and
you'd read a part of the character and
then they determine whether or not they
felt you could do it now I was very
fortunate because I was on one episode
of the x-files that Vince Gilligan wrote
and produced and he was on the set and
the character that he wrote for this
particular episode was despicable
anti-semite angry irascible this is what
happened in the car with the company yes
okay yes and and and but you still had
to feel some level of human compassion
for this man when he died as a waste of
a human life and so it does take a
little finesse to be able to walk that
line of being in one sense despicable
and any other sense he's still a human
being I still care that he you know I
don't want him to die but I didn't like
him and so there's that kind of thing
and Vince thought this is the
combination that I want for for Walter
White without Vince Gilligan I'm not
sitting in this chair right now and
you're not wearing that sweater right
John Cusack is Johnny music is sitting
in this chair yeah you did Curb Your
Enthusiasm yeah
is there any script no there's no script
Larry David's sends out a little
breakdown of the scenes that you're in
and he'll say in this scene you're going
to talk about your love of truffles and
that you you know as something else
whatever responsibilities you have as
far as information getting revealed and
then heat says what he's going to reveal
and this was the inequality of my my
chairs in my therapists office or
something and which was the first
episode I did and and then from then on
it's just it's you'd make it up and
somehow get to that point were you were
you again now I had the the great good
fortune of being in comedy boot camp
being on Seinfeld for a few years and
watching Larry David Kraft a joke like a
surgeon and Jerry and Jerry and he
working together like it talking in a
language you can't really understand
unless you're on the inside and I was
able to be watching that tennis match
between them and going oh my god they're
the timing and care it's like a souffle
it's that delicate you could crush a
joke or you can lift it just by the way
it's delivered all the time and I think
that's the key is in comedians talk
about this and and Seinfeld
we had him when did we have him your
Super Bowl about five years ago and then
so we did something we did a
pre-recorded bit and we had him assess
it and he did it in brutal terms like I
would say you need to be faster you need
to be louder take the air out here and
you should have ended it this way but he
he broke it down in real time where he's
watching it yes and you know to have
somebody a professional ear listening
for things right they don't necessarily
it's not what they see is what what they
hear and how it the cadence of it and
everything and that's what's amazing and
you're right you know you gotta that's a
fast learning curve if you're around
those two yeah
you it is and it's a lot to take in
because Jerry probably had the 10,000
hours to become proficient and expert in
that in that field and he he knows from
one night to another he go you know I
rushed that bit too fast I'm gonna pull
back on that just a touch and he and and
he crafts that and then every night is
different you have a different audience
and if you don't stand up yeah I did I
did stand up back in the 80s and the
only reason I did it was because I was
afraid of it it scared me the idea of
getting up on stage having a microphone
and a spotlight and that's it go and so
I thought oh I gotta overcome this fear
so I started doing stand-up back in the
heyday of when there's so many comedy
clubs all around and I did at The Improv
The Comedy Store The Laugh Factory
The Laugh stop the even the Playboy Club
and this is all in LA they had open mic
nights I never got paid for it
nor should I ever been paid for it I
rose to the level of mediocrity and I
remember one night I was at the laughs
stop in the valley and I had my best
night I mean I crushed and laughter and
laughter and laughter and I was so
juiced I was so excited that I got in
the car and I drove right to the improv
on Melrose and I said you got to get me
on says I got it I got it I finally got
it and the guy says well we're hang on
someone might drop out someone did drop
out and about about 10:00 to 1:00
o'clock in the morning it was like 1250
in the morning okay you can go on for
five minutes okay and I go on and that's
the same routine same night get up there
crickets just unbanned that's how hard
it is because it's like it threw me
because I thought wait a minute wait a
minute this is exactly the same set and
I know the timing of what I'm doing
nothing and it was like oh my god I
gotta get out of this
it's brutal do you think that the
better-looking you are the tougher it is
to be funny well I should know
thankfully streamlets why you're not
that funny you know you just thank you
good thank you
the Birdman of gorgeousness yeah
why could Brad Pitt be a stand-up
comedian like what would people and
that's I don't know you know not so much
I think I think when you are a
good-looking person and and you know
you've had that gift your whole life you
things are available to you that are not
available to other people but there are
some things that you're not accessible
to if you're a Wallflower if you're
introverted if you're not very
attractive you have the the luxury of
observation you can see the smart people
and the good people playing and the
good-looking people and you go wow look
at them but you can also develop you
know other skills yes boy Brian said not
very attractive he looked right towards
the four of us he didn't even he just
looked right directly at the more that
was just that was just on purpose that's
all completely no no the Danites are
gorgeous a handsome Bryan Cranston can
you stick around yeah okay welcome back
I'm gonna talk about the movie when do
you have to be on Broadway on Broadway
what time you get I get there an hour
and a half before the show starts like
5:30 okay
oh great now thanks Dan I mean did I say
5:30 I get there just two minutes before
we go on time welcome back with Bryan
Cranston after this in the damn final
show the upside with Bryan Cranston
Kevin Hart is in it Nicole Kidman good
kisser she is in the movie julianna
margulies and Tate Donovan are in the
movie it's a good movie yes and well can
you give us a synopsis here while I
still have you before your handlers yank
you know based on a true story about a
wealthy man who had a hang gliding
accident and became a quadriplegic and
he's dealing with all the the issues
that that would naturally happen and and
one day he's this man who comes into his
life by accident he hires as a personal
attendant to to help him get through his
day
and it's he's terribly unqualified but
he liked him he felt he was honest and
approachable and mrs. Kevin this is
Kevin Hart's character and they form a
friendship the very unlikely friendship
but it is true and these two men are
still friends to this day
and see each other regularly even though
they live in different countries and
this film is a take off of that and it's
it's really beautiful it's funny it's
heartfelt it's it's life-affirming and
uplifting and you make out with Nicole
Kidman I don't I wouldn't it was hard to
say that I make out with Nicole Kidman
no it would help still tickets it would
help say no no she's a lovely lovely
woman julianna margulies land margulies
yeah it she's wonderful yeah these are
talented talented co-stars yeah the
upside is really good and it's in
theaters on Friday and network if you
get a chance to come to New York go see
Network that is you it's an amazing
performance really thank you Dan and
move me to tears believe it or not just
like you so wait a minute the tears that
you did earlier in the show yes those
were fake
yes so how do I know those tears that
you were moved to buy and you don't know
oh my god I but I did when I saw you
backstage when you made time for me
after David Duchovny you spent like 15
minutes with him and I went Duchovny I
mean come on like hey like get him out
of here no it was due coming how many
Super Bowl trophies has Duchovny handed
out that's true right that's would you
check zero zero for the company he's
talking to Duchovny remember that
episode we did the x-files and home and
then all those were tears of jealousy
yes they were very much so I am happy
for you thank you buddy and thank you
for coming in meas Brian crate you can
leave now okay no your handlers want you
to long I have to actually physically
you leave this is a walk walk this is
this is it right there in that and a bad
sweater that's thank you Brian that's
Bryan Cranston
I think it's up for debate who's got a
worse sweater on and Wow I don't know if
it's of course I don't know if it's a
foregone conclusions like okay all right
you guys be honest now be honest on the
what sweater would you wear okay which
if you had to wear one of these sweater
okay which one would you Holly I love
earth tones and tweet I love his outfit
okay seat no Connor we're actually
getting tweets from viewers of the show
who want to know where Brian got the
sweater so it's that's a big hit and the
pants I like the ensemble McLovin I
don't work for Brian Dan I love your
swing going Cranston all the way by the
way great talk on on sports and football
and I was and it's always good your
handler said that you didn't want to
talk sports did not want to talk oh stop
I want to talk the craft that I'm most
familiar where is acting go Ram I'm
gonna start crying if you don't leave
alright going alright that's Bryan
Cranston I give up the upside
he's with Kevin Hart Nicole Kidman and
Julianne Moore goalies in theaters for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]